[MUSIC PLAYING]
PETER LEWIS: Beacons aren't new.
We've had them for thousands
and thousands of years
where, typically at
sea, they've been
used to mark important
places around the coastlines
of countries.
The new Open Beacon
format from Google-- it
performs exactly
the same purpose.
It marks an important
point so that when
users' devices are
moving through the world,
they can have a much better
idea about the important objects
and places that are around them.
ROS VAN DER LANS: For
Amsterdam, the public transport
is very important.
We have a very
dense infrastructure
designed for horse and buggy.
In this project, we are
deploying thousands of Beacons
in trams, metros, and buses.
PETER LEWIS: Google's
Beacon platform
allows deployers of Beacons,
like the City of Amsterdam,
to associate information
with their Beacons,
and then make them
available to all developers.
ROS VAN DER LANS: We
are working on getting
a data-driven, real-time city.
CARMEN RUIZ VICENTE: With
Google Beacon platform,
we wanted to focus
on simplicity,
so that developers
can focus on features.
AXEL ROEST: Art Whisperer
is an application
that combines public data
about art with Beacons
to tell you about the
art piece you're looking
at in a non-intrusive way.
When you walk down
the street, it
will tell you what
you're staring at.
If you walk away, it
will fade out again.
TIM DE KRAKER: So
we actually created
an app that helps you to
have better experiences when
you go out.
From all the bars
around, which place
is best for you at that moment?
Let's use the fact that we
know someone is in a bar,
and close the loop between
the online part of his life
and the offline
part of his life.
And that's where Beacons
have a great opportunity.
KATHERINE PAYNE: Wayfindr
allows developers
and built environment
owners to understand
how they can use
Beacon technology
to allow blind people to
navigate their indoor spaces
using their smartphones.
We want to be able to make sure
that whether you're getting off
a plane in Sydney, taking
the Metro in New York,
or landing in Amsterdam, you get
the same consistent, reliable
instructions through
a smartphone.
PAUL MANWARING:
What's a smart city?
Cities aren't smart.
People are smart.
People make cities interactive.
It's about creating moments
where those objects can connect
that person to history,
or culture, or education,
or mobility, or another person.
PETER LEWIS: We're excited to
see Beacon technology being
rolled out in cities, so that
we can see what innovation
developers bring to the table.
[MUSIC PLAYING]